well it's game night at the fortress the
golden knights have
a chance to knock out the colorado
avalanche
with a big win tonight we have live team
coverage for you john treach is standing
by but first let's head out
to sports director chris matthews who
has a preview for us chris
i'll tell you what guys this is
certainly the calm before the storm
there'll be 18 000
medieval maniacs here going nuts in
about what two hours from right now so
it's
it's kind of the calm here before the
place goes really crazy but the vegas
golden knights
are looking to become of course the
third team to advance
into the third round in this first four
years of existence now if they do win
tonight and move into the semis
of the stanley cup playoffs they will be
the third team in nhl history
to do that first since way back in 1970
when the saint blue
st louis blues did it now here's a
concern though vegas
has a lead best of seven series here 3-2
but has
lost game six in three or four times now
but the abs have won game six in each of
the past two seasons
when trotting 3-2 in the series so the
knights understand what lies ahead
and that's getting colorado's best shot
well we just got to embrace the
opportunity you know you're going to get
their best game
uh i think guys are smart enough to
understand the
the opportunity that's in front of us
here and uh
you got to embrace that and and just go
play a great hockey game
i think you know we're gonna have the
fans behind us we're at home
uh where else would you want to be you
know i don't think anybody
and if they are they're lying after game
two predicted we'd have an opportunity
to close this team out
in game six at home so um other than the
guys in our room
you know the belief there and
we're here and let's take let's take
advantage of it
[Music]
all right here is an interesting stat
right now after the knights lost game
two and were down 0-2 in the series
the abs had an 87 chance of winning that
series
then vegas reeled off three in a row now
leading the series 3-2 it is the golden
knights
that have a 79 percent chance of winning
this series
one note here today this morning the
avalanche coach
jared bednar was not at morning skate he
was taken away
because there were concerns about his
covet testing some irregularities
in his cobit testing so he wasn't there
but within the last hour he has been
cleared to coach the colorado avalanche
while much more of the knights of those
medieval maniacs that we get set for the
game tonight
let's head it outside where john treach
is standing by hey john
thanks so much chris he has so many
story lines with the avalanche golden
knights but also
for this passionate and truly historic
fan base
four years four playoff trips and
another chance
to clinch which would be awesome history
right here on the home ice
i'm with this awesome family we've got
three cousins here and you've all
coordinated your jerseys and steve
what is the best part of going to this
potentially historic
playoff game just hearing the fans grow
wild in there
it's always a great game so and and to
have your family here i mean
i gotta believe this is something you're
gonna remember for years oh yeah the
kids love coming to the games
we always have great memories from each
game we go to and
are you sometimes taken back by the
noise because even where we are in press
row it's
it's deafening oh yeah she actually
usually brings her
headphones so she doesn't have to hear
most of it but yeah it's great in there
it's so loud
awesome and uh well congratulations guys
you gotta you gotta admire the
coordination here we got all
all three jerseys here and hopefully for
pats ready marchessault
they can get it done so a great family
here and a great fan base as
they look to see history and another
clinch on holme ice
reporting live outside t-mobile arena
about two hours from puck drop
john treach eight sports now thank you
john we know it's going to get loud
indeed they are ready for it so
are we